I want to start off by asking you a bit
about what philip hammond told me
earlier on the show i don't know if you
managed to watch the interview but he
basically said that if we don't get a
deal then he'll have to take a different
approach to Britain's economy that we
need to be a new budget next year now of
course we don't know what will be in
that new budget but it could be asked
Jacob Riis mark was speculating earlier
it could be you know tax cuts it could
be something to do with regulation is it
something that worries you
I found the whole interview really
shocking to be honest I think you did as
well looking from your expression I
thought it was absolutely well
I've well I thought it was callous
complacency that came across about this
week's budget but also about the future
but you spoke to him about universal
credit and the hardship that people have
been threatened with losing to three
million people who's in turn are
thousand pounds a year go to food banks
as a result of it and he's barely
mentioned it what we're saying and it's
not just me it's the National Audit
Office it's large numbers of charitable
organizations and others basically
saying halt the rollout of universal
credit to stop these people being forced
into poverty halt the rollout and I'm
saying to other political parties that
if he doesn't halt the rollout of
universal credit we've got to vote this
budget down we've got to stop him
forcing people into poverty in this way
and then when you asked him about brexit
I was really shocked he's gone back to
what he said some time ago which is
basically he seems to have accepted a no
deal brexit and he does want us to be
like Singapore they sort of tax haven
which will undermine our manufacturing
base and I think put people's living
standards at risk I was really shocked
by the interview really shocked well to
be fair to the Chancellor he did say
that he wanted to see a deal that that's
something that he was hoping for and so
I put it to you that if you are so
concerned and by what the government may
do in an ideal scenario with the
responsible thing for labour to be doing
is to at least have on the table
supporting the deal that Therese made
I think you misinterpreted this shift
that he's undertaken in this last couple
of weeks in that interview he seemed to
complacently except that though there's
a likelihood out a likelihood of no deal
we can't accept that we've got to ensure
that there is a deal and the best way of
doing that is treason they negotiate in
a proper deal that protects jobs and the
economy and if she can't do that she
should step to one side because there's
too much at risk from a No Deal and if
she can't do it i sell-- let labor get
on with the negotiations or let's have
that general election and let the people
decide so just to be clear would you
support a deal that Theresa May comes
back with if you think it is the best or
at least a reasonable way of protecting
jobs because looking at your six Tests I
mean one of them is to deliver the exact
same benefits as we currently have as
members of the single markets and
customs union I mean that's impossible
isn't it no matter who's the negotiating
fees well those tests are basically the
tests of what they set themselves this
is what they promised us they said she
said David Davis said exactly the same
benefit so our tests are based upon what
the government promised us but we've
said time and time again bring back a
deal that protect jobs in the economy
and yes of course we'll support it but
the problem that we've got a we should
use we saw it in your interview with
Philip Hammond she's got people in the
cabinet now even the Chancellor by the
looks of it
who willing to risk our economy really
to risk our economy on the basis of a No
Deal because he has fantasies about us
being like Singapore off the coast of
with off the coast of Europe as a tax
haven
threatening our manufacturing base and
threatening our economy I found that
interview deeply deeply worrying a
little bit earlier on you were just
saying there about the neighbor sixth
has being based on what the government
promised so are you telling me then that
Labour is deciding on how to vote one of
the most important issues that you know
our country is faced in decades on the
basis is something that David Davis
wants that
no I'm saying what the Prime Minister
has said say that in the Commons because
she repeated exactly what David Davis
said giving those assurances but what
we're saying I'm very very clearly in
Jeremy Corbyn said it at a party
conference we want a deal that would
protect jobs and the economy if that the
Prime Minister brings that back we will
support it but you know as well as I do
it's almost impossible for her to get
this through either her own cabinet or
her own party and certainly not through
Parliament by looks of it because the
DUP exercises a veto over all matters
what we need now is proper negotiations
I say again if this cut worth the
conservative party can't do it because
they're in such disarray step to one
side and let the Labour Party come
forward do the negotiations in the
interest of the country because we
believe we can secure a deal that will
protect jobs in the economy overall the
last thing we need now is these threats
from Philip Hammond or others that
they're willing to prepare for a No Deal
okay and now of course you know I'm sure
Philip Hammond would say that you know
it's the responsible thing to be
preparing for No Deal I'm keen to talk
to you about austerity as well Theresa
may want a No Deal bye that's right
Theresa May promised an end to austerity
Philip Hammond said at the interview
we're now at a turning point so do you
believe that by tomorrow austerity is
going to be over of course not well
there's a test isn't there Teresa
Merritt mayor's announced f30 isn't at
the end let's see in this budget let's
see actually if we are going to get all
the money the health service needs he's
announced 20 billion but we've been told
by the experts the Health Foundation
that that simply isn't enough
that's a standstill budget in fact we
now know the Health Service has got
something like 11 billion pounds in the
red so a lot of that money will be taken
up by just covering past deficits we've
mentioned schools headteacher
how much what it could be said whatever
here well we've said already we put our
budget forward last year in the general
election 49 billion pounds worth of
investment in our public services
overall paid for yes by increases in
taxes on the top 5% of earners
cutting back on Talk Corporation two tax
giveaways and tax giveaways to the rich
that would be a start and we would
invest in our economy and grow our
economy in a way which would afford our
public services
I wanna found absolutely amazing in your
interview as well these complacency
about schools for 18,000 schools out
there at least that having budget cuts
we've got teachers and head teachers
marching on number ten because of the
cuts that are occurring there schools at
the moment hey teachers sending out
begging letters I thought the whole
interview around the public services as
well was completely complacent cut off
from the real world that most people are
experiencing out there you were just out
learning there some of labor's measures
that you have already outlined so
corporation tax increasing income tax
for 5% but described it as the start
because ending austerity would cost more
than that wouldn't it so where are you
going to find the money from well we've
said that's our first stage budget that
we'd introduce and when we go into the
last general election when the next
general election is announced we'll
publish a new manifesto it will be fully
costed and yes we'll invest to grow our
economy and you know that's the problem
with austerity it was wrong from the
beginning well soon as you introduced
austerity in the earliest well 2010
onwards you held the economy back so as
a result of that you delayed the
recovery and that meant look wages
started well that wages were cut for
most people they still are and at the
same time our public services of our
social fabric was being undermined what
this is by the way well by the prime
minister in particular is an acceptance
that actually austerity has failed and
people are not going to put up with it
anymore
that's why we need investment in our
economy to grow the economy so that we
can afford the public services we need
on the basis of a fair taxation system
just want to nail you down on the
figures because this is important
according to reports this week you said
it would cost around 108 billion pounds
to end austerity is that right we said
this is what the cuts have amounted to
over the last ten years it's the scale
we wanted to point out to the government
are you gonna reverse we're going to do
is exactly what we asked we're going to
start the process off of making sure we
have a fair taxation system invest in
our public services and you know the
best way of reversing austerity is
investing in our economy the thing this
governments fail to do business
investment now at a well stagnating
government investment cutback and as a
result of that you know in the first six
months of this year we had the lowest
growth in our economy since 2011 last
year the lowest growth in our economy in
the g7 if you don't invest you don't
grow the economy and as a result of that
you can't invest in your public services
we're going to have a fair taxation
system mabus to pay for our public
services in that way and neighbors still
invest in our economy grow the economy
in that way everybody will share in that
prosperity